and tonight we start by looking at the
failures of joe biden's presidency every
step of the way biden has let america
down the left was so concerned with
getting rid of the mean orange man and
his tweets they were willing to crash
the economy and ruin your life just to
get their way 10 months into biden's
presidency and it looks like the
american people are having second
thoughts as joe biden's approval rating
has crumbled to an unsustainable 38
percent
while nearly two-thirds of the country
that's 64 percent don't want biden to
run for a second term and that's
including almost 30 percent of democrats
i bet donald trump is looking at a lot
better to most of those voters from
biden's embarrassing retreat in
afghanistan to his ability inability to
contain the supply chain crisis to surge
in inflation that is about to make your
thanksgiving a hell of a lot more
expensive it is clear his administration
has no answers to the plaguing problems
in our country let's just take a look at
the gas pump where the price of fuel has
jumped more than 1.25
in just the last year so what's the
white house plan to fix this
why is the administration now
considering shutting down the line five
pipeline from canada to michigan so
peter uh that is inaccurate that is not
comp that is not right
but the reporting the reporting about uh
us wanting to shut down the line five
is it is it being studied right now is
the administration studying the impact
of shutting down the line five yes we
are
see in the south we would say they're
stuck on stupid that's right they're
thinking about shutting down yet another
pipeline here in america did they forget
how that turned out last time when they
shut down the keystone xl
pipeline so much for american energy
independence
it's not just gas prices that are
soaring just ask energy secretary
jennifer granholm
should americans in what will likely be
a cold winter most of them are expect to
pay
higher
prices for heating their homes yeah
this is going to happen it will be uh it
will be more expensive this year than
last year
yeah so that was grand home doing her
best jimmy carter impression telling us
to put on a sweater this winter because
your home is going to get cold hey at
least it was better than her last answer
on surging fuel costs watch
oh my god
that is hilarious
what's up with all the
these guys laughing this administration
is literally laughing at us as they take
more and more money out of our wallets
but don't ask them to actually explain
what is happening because they don't
think that you're smart enough to
understand it
we were all
going out and having lunch together and
i said
let's ask whoever whoever's in the next
table no matter how
what restaurant we're in have haven't
explained the supply chain to us
you think they'd understand what we're
talking about
you can understand why people are upset
and i'd whether you have a phd or you're
or you're working you know in a
restaurant
it's confusing
well mr president you're right it is
confusing but maybe you're the one who
doesn't understand what's going on why
else would he ask around the room to see
if some liberal journalist could explain
it for him watch
you all right for a living
i haven't seen any one of you explain
supply chain very well when your editor
says explain the supply chain
okay
this is a confusing time
so we get it mr president you're
confused maybe you're second in command
kambala harris has a handle on the
situation
can you measure um
trees
part of that data that you're referring
to
and it's an ej it's environmental
justice but you can also track
by race
there are averages in terms of the
number of trees in the neighborhood
where people live
so much of that was disturbing
so forget the supply chain issues kamala
caught up with trees we can't make this
stuff up these people are running our
country or not
it's no wonder why calmly's approval
rating is even worse than joe biden's
coming at an embarrassing 28
it it's clear that this administration
is way over their heads let's just hope
they don't burn the whole thing down
before the midterms
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else